the Titanic is such a famous shipwreck
not because the most number of people
died there are plenty of other
shipwrecks where more people died but
because it had all of the ingredients
for a good story
had rich people dying which is something
for some reason we all think about it
had this Mystique about like it being
like Unsinkable and then it sunk it was
covered in the newspaper in like a
really significant way and it had a
bunch of like personal human tension
that other shipwrecks just didn't have
or if it did have it never got covered
we selectively decide what we remember
and often the things we remember as a
society hundreds of years later are the
things that had these ingredients that
had a good story that had significant
people or High Society people who were
affected it's maybe not the way it
should be but that's the way it is